thomas de crie ton nom trois personnes
ont été massacrées allemand tout 3
répondant au nom de ben là tu diriez
quoi si votre homonyme sauf sécurité
hautement yard a décidé de rassembler
tous les bennes light vivant à londres
dans le but d'assurer leur protection
qu'est ce qui te fait croire que tu est
le prochain sur la liste le nom ma
chaîne youtube c'est je m'appelle ben
like tu as tu ici
pourquoi vous me regarder comme ça parce
que je suis bac moi j'avais même pas
tous blacks
[Musique]
montréal
nous
je voulais vous suggérer de faire une
petite prière ont fait leur match et
gagnent moins de kant est dangereux
c'est ma bulle
droite dans ce fief
[Musique]
qu'est ce que t'as foutu c'était un
accident non ça grecque tout exprès art
ou mentale
[Musique]
je peux mieux faire là mais on aura
temps à autre on peut peut-être
s'arranger thomert
[Musique]